if mr biden's plans were enacted the
government would spend what amounts to
nearly a quarter of the nation's total
economic output
every year no or not
you're a stupid stupid man stupid i'm
not going to let you get the chance
stupid total debt held by the public
would more than exceed the annual value
of economic output
rising to 117 percent of the size of the
economy
in 2031. by 2024
debt as a share of the economy would
rise to its highest level in american
history
eclipsing its world war ii era record
for what for what
what are you even talking about why
honestly god why
right now he's saying we're predicting
the greatest american economic growth
since the 1980s
you know what we should do what if we
just spend a load of money for no reason
at all
what if we blow out the debt to the tune
of the worst
debt as a share of the economy ever
like including world war ii when we were
fighting world wars and had mobilized
the entire
male civilian population between the
ages of 18 and 40 and put them in
barracks
what in the i mean this is it's totally
crazy and the media is like well you
know well he is trying to shore up that
middle class
oh you mean the middle class that ended
this year with more savings than it had
last year thanks to government largesse
according to the new york times the
levels of taxation and spending in mr
biden's plans would expand the federal
fiscal footprint to levels
rarely seen in the post-war era rarely
never to fund investments that his
administration says are crucial
to keeping america competitive that
includes money for roads i love that
it's about roads guys are spending six
trillion dollars
for roads no
we're not again if you believe this
you're a stupid
stupid man stupid
it includes money for roads water pipes
broadband internet electric vehicle
charging stations
and advanced manufacturing research okay
you know what that's going to comprise
like
this percent of the budget like as a
percentage of that total six trillion
dollar budget
it was like that that kind of stuff was
like five to ten percent
of the infrastructure plan that was a
true trillion dollar plan this is a six
trillion dollar plan
it also envisions funding for affordable
childcare universal pre-k a national
paid leave program and a host of other
initiatives
spending on national defense would also
grow though though it would decline as a
share of the economy we'll get to
national defense in just a second
because
the biden administration is continuing
its quest to occupy the military
the documents suggest mr biden will not
propose major additional policies in the
budget
or that his budget will flesh out plans
that the administration has thus far
declined to detail for example
biden pledged to overhaul and upgrade
the nation's unemployment insurance
program as part of the american family's
plans
but such efforts are not included in his
budget right that's a separate plan
that he's still proposing the budget is
simply a request to congress which must
approve federal spending both democrats
in control of both chambers of congress
biden faces some of the best odds of any
president in recent history and having
much of his agenda approved
particularly if he can reach agreement
with lawmakers on parts of his
infrastructure agenda
if mr biden's plans were enacted again
this is the new york times i love how
they bury the lead here
if mr biden's plans were enacted the
government would spend what amounts to
nearly a quarter of the nation's total
economic output
every year over the course of the next
decade
it would collect tax revenues equal to
just under one-fifth of the total
economy
how are they going to make up that
difference by selling your bonds of
course by selling bonds to china
or by having the federal reserve
essentially manufacture money
in order to pay for all of this in each
year of biden's budget the government
would spend more as a share of the
economy than all but two years since
world war ii
2020 and 2021 which is because we blew
out the budget
in order to shore up the pandemic
response by the way
who thinks that his budget is going to
be his total spending which president
has the budget been the only budgetary
move that's been made over the course of
the year this is this is madness
by 2028 the government would be
collecting more tax revenue as a share
of the economy than almost any point in
modern statistical history
the documents also show the conservative
approach biden's economic team is taking
with regard to projecting the economy's
growth biden's aides predicted even if
his full agenda were enacted the economy
would grow at just under two percent
for most of the decade after accounting
for inflation which is sluggish
i mean at least they're being realistic
about that he will produce sluggish
growth
unemployment would fall to 4.1 percent
by next year from 6.1 percent today and
remain below 4
in the years thereafter oh would it
really as you inflate all the prices by
blowing money into the economy
do you think that unemployment that
people continue to hire
at extraordinary rates and this is this
is
ridiculous the biden forecast continues
to show his administration has little
fear of rap and inflation breaking out
across the economy
despite recent data showing a quick jump
in prices under the biden team's
projections consumer prices never rise
faster than 2.3
per year well weird because year on year
according to the last
available metric the inflation was like
4.2 percent like twice
almost twice that biden says that now is
a great time
because the interest rates are low for
us to basically just blow money into the
economy
which is actually a terrible time to
blow money into the economy because that
creates bubbles
i love this interest rates are
controlled by the federal reserve which
is independence of the white house yeah
super independent
super independence over at that federal
reserve you know who's running the
federal reserve until five seconds ago
janet yellen who's currently the
secretary of the treasury under wait for
it
president house plant even if the
interests stay low
interest rates stay low payments on the
national debt would consume an increased
share of the federal budget
net interest payments would double as a
share of the economy from 2022 to 2031.
okay this is it's just insane it's just
insane
okay so his plan is to blow out the
spending in the middle
of a natural economic recovery and in
the middle of an inflationary spiral
in order to do what he wants his legacy
here's the bottom line he wants his
legacy
that guy knows he's not running for
reelection he wants to be a
consequential president and therefore
he's just going to blow out the spending
because who cares
somebody else is going to have to deal
with that down the line
unreal and it also it's incredible that
supposedly if you confiscate
25 of the american gdp every year from
taxpayers which by the way is a minimum
it'll be more
if he does that then that's gonna have
no impact on gdp growth which will
continue to grow steadily at two percent
and inflation which will continue to
just be two percent a year it's just
nuts i'm sorry this is fantasyland
bullcrap
we all get what we deserve if we decide
to go forward with this how's this for a
title
ben shapiro show subscriber destroys
like button with clicks and logic
i'd watch that make it happen gang